[Music]
[Applause]
Marcellus Wiley the former All-Pro
defensive and host uh more to it on The
Dan Patrick Podcast Network also a host
of never shut up on Brinks TV that's a
new one that he has coming up also on
the podcast he uh talks about the Hall
of Famers he thinks who were going into
the Hall of Fame also if you have a
losing team do you want Jim Harbaugh or
Sean Payton Marcellus joins us on the
program all right I'll give you Sean
Payton Jim Harbaugh who do you want on
your team
I'm going with Jim Harbaugh there's
something about the way that he
approaches the game the intensity that
he possesses obviously being a former
player there is some form of connection
there but it's the fact that he reminds
me of someone that if we needed another
man up if we need it next man up the
12th man on the field will be coach Jim
Harbaugh I know he has the mind the
Brilliance and obviously Sean Payton I'm
taking no slights at him we're having a
Marvin Gaye Sam Cooke discussion right
now in terms of coaching but when it
comes to what Jim Harbaugh possesses I
think he gets the most out of his
players in part because he carries the
same juice and electricity today they
possess so Jim Harbaugh just seems like
a guy who could transmit his message
across the sidelines in a greater
capacity and greater passion that's the
guy I would choose do you have to like
your head coach to play for him not at
all not at all you have to have the
ability to compartmentalize and know the
difference between like and respect so
you got to respect what he says and you
got to respect that he's going to bring
discipline you got to respect that he's
going to do the proper things in terms
of play calling you got to respect that
he's going to put the team in best
situations and the logistics of it all
like he's going to give you proper
scheduling proper rest proper practice
time you got to respect it you don't
have to like it because sometimes
especially when I play we would have
Double Days sometime triple days no one
liked it but we respected it because we
knew that this was going to end up with
a greater result so it's all about the
process which you go through who cares
how it really feels as long as it turns
out well we spent a lot of time this
morning talking about the non-playoff
teams because they're interesting right
now and you got the Bears who have the
number one overall pick and their GM
said look Justin Fields is our
quarterback unless I'm Blown Away by an
offer which means if I'm Blown Away by
an offer then Justin Fields probably
isn't my quarterback if you're the GM of
the Bears and you have the number one
overall pick and you have Justin fields
what are you doing
you know one he's already tipping his
hand because what he stated was the
obvious every player is tradable if
you're Blown Away by the offer I don't
care who you are blown away by the offer
says a lot and the reason he said that
is because I don't think he needs to be
blown away by the offer because that's
pretty obvious I think this is something
that they're a little closer to in terms
of thinking of moving on from Justin
Fields that's why he's putting it out
there hey if you're one Justin Fields
he's available with you blow me away
with your offer and I didn't like that
because now you're putting Justin fields
in a position where the chances are he
stays he does have some capabilities to
go out there and help this team win
especially when he runs the ball
especially when the play breaks down
obviously that's not repeatable that's
not something that you can call a
reliable offense but he is doing some
positive things but I think if you had
to place a bet on this one they're
trying their damnness to move on from
Justin Fields because I think they won a
quarterback in the more traditional
capacity yes a pocket Pastor who has the
ability to run instead of a guy who has
his struggles at times in the pocket but
still can run the ball but um Seton
brought this up earlier and he was
listening to an analyst say sometimes
your quarterback resembles the
conditions they play in like Josh Allen
looks like Buffalo like you got to be
big and strong and you know but I go
back to Jim McMahon played in Chicago
and he wasn't a big guy Bryce young is
not a big guy so I don't know if if that
really would factor in if I'm looking at
Chicago and going he's not built to be a
Chicago quarterback what do you think
about the elements with your quarterback
yeah I think when you're an organization
you're trying to draft someone who can
withstand those conditions those
elements um I think we place two much
burden and too much greetings on that I
think we think about it too much like
Doug Flutie is the itty bitty right he
played in Buffalo better than the big
strong statue Rob Johnson did you know
uh I think it doesn't matter when it
comes down to if the quarterback has the
talent he has the mentality and he has
the proper pieces around him you can
play any quarterback in any condition
that said when you're evaluating uh it's
hard to measure intangibles and it's
hard to measure how someone's going to
deal with that adversity which includes
the elements let's be real before you go
out to a game before you even face your
opponent the other team you're thinking
about how you feel and if you don't feel
good in those elements you don't stand a
chance against the guys with the other
colors on
do you think the Cardinals are
regretting locking up Kyler
no because I don't think the Cardinals
fully understand
the consequences of their choices uh the
cliff Kingsbury you sign them to an
extension and now he's not your coach
you have a quarterback franchise
quarterback who was an MVP candidate
before injury last year came back this
year I don't know what this was but he
has talent he is a tremendous talent but
the problem is when you sign him to an
extension you leak out or put out that
he needs to study more so I just don't
think this organization really knows
which way is up so therefore they don't
know the consequences of their actions
that said they need to get some strong
leadership they need someone that they
respect that they don't like as we were
saying earlier they need someone
upstairs and on that sideline that is
just going to Buck everything that is
the Cardinal's way right now because
they're not getting the most out of
their results they're not getting the
most out of their talent and that's why
this team is in this situation
what if the Cowboys get blown out
oh I don't want to hear it I don't want
to see it because I know the sky will
fall like we always are in prediction of
the sky falling when it comes to the
Cowboys it would fall if they were to
lose this week and in blowout fashion
just because we saw this team show some
tremendous potential we saw them going
to win streak we saw them look like a
team that's a real Contender and if that
is not realized or even scratched in
terms of them clawing their way to the
NFC Championship Game and losing a tight
one or even being in the Super Bowl I
just know there are going to be a lot of
changes with that organization obviously
starting on the sideline with Michael
carty this is a story that hasn't gotten
a lot of attention and I did bring it up
today
we're under the impression Tom Brady is
playing next year
right yeah yeah I am Monday could be his
last game
like if they lose
but but you know we love
to go at Tom Brady uh last game Monday
night question mark and then all these
shows discuss it right yeah yeah well
look he he just got a divorce and I
think everybody out there all sports
fans man or woman knows that when you
get a divorce it's time to live it's
time to party and the way that Tom Brady
lives and parties is going out there
chasing Super Bowl championships I don't
think I couldn't imagine playing all of
these years at that level of greatness
and I'm married and it becomes a burden
it becomes a hindrance it gets to the
point where we have contention we get
divorced and then that season after my
divorce is my last season oh hell no I'm
letting the dogs loot it's time to go
out there and hunt and see what it is
and there is something there's a dynamic
to the athlete that when he is single
and allowed to mingle you get a lot more
bang for your buck out of that athlete
whether we are Tiger Woods we we are
Deion Sanders we are a thousand other
athletes that I would name none of them
point being there's something about that
energy that you get when you're single I
want to see Tom Brady out there single
brother Marshall yeah but he doesn't
drink I mean he's not having any fun
well I mean look the only reason people
drink is to get to the place where
they're going to have fun right he just
skips that step he's like I don't need
that I don't need to hang over I'm gonna
wake up and do it again um Tom Brady's
passing us uh Marcellus Wiley the former
All-Pro defensive end and uh host of
more to it podcast on the DP Show
Network and host of never shut up on
Brinks TV uh you mentioned that uh you
have the five players you think are
going into the Hall of Fame this year
yeah okay
um I I want to save that for the podcast
yeah it's on the podcast so everyone
knows the finalist list but uh give me a
surprise give me one can you give me one
surprise of the five that you you think
are going in
no okay I can't even teach it's not a
surprise like once you see the list and
you stop trying to be nice and send
Hallmark cards to all the favorite
players that were great when you start
really breaking this down it gets pretty
obvious and that's kind of the bit that
I went through on the podcast like the
finalist list comes out and every fan
base gets activated oh he was the best
he he was however the best of the best
is a different conversation you got to
listen for it uh just got an update uh
from the bills tomorrow Hamlin has been
discharged from Buffalo General Medical
Center and he is headed home
unreal unbelievable
I mean seriously we throw that around so
often unbelievable this one truly was
unbelievable flatlined twice not once
twice and no one's thinking about
football right now just the fact that
what a remarkable outcome man tremendous
blessings to him man so amazing I mean
much less than nine days
okay look I bring levity to everything I
laugh at My Pain so since he's out the
hospital now seems like he's in the
clear and if I'm in the locker room like
I'm in the locker room this is what I
say dog how you gonna die twice and come
back faster than if I get an ACL like
dogs
hey if you can't play football again
trust me he's all pro every year it's
gonna be unreal yeah guy who's got a
calf strain you know he can't come back
Demar almost died twice hey if I play
for Cincinnati this week and Lamar
Jackson is out there or if he's not I'm
like look hell you not playing it
tomorrow twice
that's what happens in the locker room
man hey uh well you can listen to the
podcast and uh Marcellus will tell you
the five players who deserve to go into
the Hall of Fame and the new TV show
never shut up that uh at debuts on
Brinks TV today what is never shut up
gonna be oh never shut up man it's gonna
be exactly this Dynamic the locker room
which I declare was the last place where
everyone was real everyone came in there
whether in agreement or disagreement
punching throwing everything the truth
shall set you free and then we walk away
respectfully and go out there and handle
our work so the show is going to be
about us starting the conversations
where most of the time out in public we
end the conversation so we're just going
to go deeper about all the topics that
we all are affected by for some reason
not really speaking on what's the worst
locker room fight you ever saw
the worst fight
um it actually ended with a smile you
know when we used to play we were
allowed to Haze and The Hazing was real
so Ted Washington nicknamed Mount
Washington
66370 his fingers look like thighs
um got into it with Pat Williams who's a
baby Mount Washington
um Thurman Thomas uh who else Bruce
Smith got one arm in there he didn't
want to basically they tied him up and
this is hard to do because Pat Williams
was stronger than strong tied him up
butt naked in the Buffalo cold and taped
them to the goal post poured water on
them baby powder and let them freeze and
left them in the freeze but thankfully
we had a good training staff that
finally figured out what was going on
that was the funniest most rockest fight
I've ever seen that might be a violation
now it might be a violation might be I I
think with our PC culture right now uh
you don't even get to the baby that
might get you five days in jail if you
even baby pot or someone Marcellus thank
you oh I appreciate it David take care
brother all right Brinks TV today with
Marcellus and uh the podcast more to it